I'm really especially happy that I'm
chosen to present this particular plaque
to me it seems and more than dust a
plaque of gold it opens the doors of
this room moves back the walls and
enables us to embrace the whole of
America an America that we love an
America that almost alone in the world
today recognizes and pays tribute to
those who give their best regardless of
creed race or color it is with the
knowledge that this entire nation will
stand and salute the presentation of
this plaque that I resent the Academy
Award for the best performance of an
actress in supporting role during 1939
the Hattie McDaniel
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Science fellow members of the motion
picture industry and honored guests this
is one of the happiest moments of my
life and I want to thank each one of you
who had a part in selecting me for one
of the awards for your kindness it has
made me feel very very humble and I
shall always hold it as a beacon for
anything that I may be able to do in the
future I sincerely hope I shall always
be a credit to my race and to the motion
picture industry my heart is too full to
tell you just how for you and may I say
thank you